Margaret: YouTube community
Freesoulja I completely agree with you.
The most important thing we can do in 2008
and every other year is to make sure we invest
in our children.
Really we invest in all human beings, because
you are absolutely right.
When people are educated, when they have skills
and abilities, this world becomes a much better
place.
We have a responsibility I think to do that
for our children. To --
As we in our US parliament say "leave no child
behind."
That means that every single kid of every
zip code, every race in every community has
to have the opportunities to be successful
in this world.
The other thing I would say to young people
is make sure you invest in yourself, invest
in your own education.
Take responsibility for yourself.
Get the opportunities at your local community
college and in your public schools so that
you can be a true global participant.
And I would also say that every person needs
to know that they can make a difference.
They can contribute, they can give back, they
can save a life, they can teach a child, they
can be a good mom or dad.
So Freesoulja, you go.